joining us right now to talk about
everything going on in the nfl maybe
even especially the nfc which is the
uh the fox is the home of from nfl on
fox and one of our favorite humans pro
football hall of famer howie long how
are you howie
i'm good rich how are you in the family
uh we are we're doing well
we're we're doing a lot i mean you're
you're you're past the the age of the
kids being at home
um you know as about so we're doing the
home zooming the home school
zooming we got a lot of that going on
yeah chris is doing
chris is doing that too and it's you
know it's a challenge it's a real
challenge
i'm sure particularly when you've got a
you know four year old and
yeah you know then you have a
two-year-old and
that's who they're around but they
facetime you right they facetime you and
diana
thank god for face time right it's the
greatest thing for granted
me up but could you ever imagine a world
where we could
we could still remain so close in a
really challenging time it's been
it's been a godsend so uh let's talk
about this season which has been
uh technically you could also say a
godsend for sports obviously that we're
12 weeks and we're through it
um with uh five more weeks to go in this
regular season
i i have got like one big shrug emoji to
use another 21st century term
uh when it comes to the nfc and the best
team
within it i'll give you the floor on
this one howie what do you got for me
here
oh you know i i like
i like new orleans uh
and green bay i think it's a better
match up for them
than it would be for a team like tampa
bay who's so physical
and you know we we saw what happened
earlier in the year and it was almost
it was almost kind of a carbon copy of
you know the two trips out to san
francisco and you know there was another
game
mixed in there against the physical team
where they they came up short
uh aaron is playing at such a high level
um you know i like the head coach and
it's that
that whole group of young coaches who
were
were on the washington staff under mike
shanahan and
you know it's it's not the same offense
but it's you know it's it certainly has
elements in each one of their offenses
that that look
very similar you know the pre-step
motion the jet sweeps the play-action
pass
all that um my question with new orleans
is you know taysom hill
you know who you love is a football
player a big
physical athletic uh you know we had
heard you know
a year ago that jason hill when drew
moved on was going to be the guy and
and then obviously they they make the
signing in
in the off-season you know with jameis
and you know the assumption was well
that's the natural
that's right kind of succession and you
know maybe the best thing for jameis is
spend time with sean payton and drew
brees and
you know the maturity level goes up and
the acumen goes up and all that
and we had heard a year ago that it was
going to take some hill
and i said there's no way i mean how
could that be possible
he's still yet to throw a touchdown pass
that's true um it's true
but you know it i think the real
test comes rich when
you know you get down early in a game
and
you've got to climb back into it and you
can't do it with
you know the the kind of offense they're
running now but i think
sean has looked at these other and sean
is so creative and
you know just watching what they do
offensively it's it's so fascinating to
watch
um i think he's been looking at these
other offenses and saying wait a second
i've been doing this for 15 years with a
stationary quarterback and you know
and it was it was that team that kind of
brought on
the value of the interior three in the
offensive line because of
drew's height um and and i think other
teams have kind of copied that formula
to a certain extent but uh i think he's
looked at
looked at other teams and said you know
i see what san francisco's doing i see
what green bay's doing i see with these
other teams that are
you know running all these kind of wild
formations and pre-snap motions and jet
sweeps and all that
and let's see what i can do well i mean
you know and
and i think though howie the the real
challenge might come this week
because the real challenge is facing a
team that's already seen
him before and atlanta has and i know
atlanta atlanta
is the atlanta's the southpaw that
nobody wants to fight that's
what i'm saying you know what i mean i'm
telling you it's like
it's like you know if you could explain
atlanta to me
hey it's mind-boggling
uh you know they're a team that
can just as we saw last week
unfortunately
light you up and and then they can lay
an egg
uh and you know new orleans sac sacked
him
what eight times and uh you know i
i think uh that defensive front
you know looks at that on the calendar
and says
that's a three sacker for me i know and
that's and that's why the saints have
might might be you know uh super bowl
worthy is the way the defense is playing
but
you know it's one of those i don't know
and i know that the the defense had its
day against atlanta two weeks ago as you
just mentioned
but rich that's been coming with their
defense their defenses
you know i think they had communication
issues um
i i think in in in some ways they
you know they started slow particularly
on the back end
and somewhat up front but they got
players back
and you know we forget that defense was
pretty good coming down the stretch
last year and and i think they've kind
of stepped it back up and
you know it but once again the question
becomes
what happens when you're down in a big
game you know maybe not this week but
maybe
down the road and maybe it's in the you
know
divisional round or and hopefully for
them the nfc
championship game where you're down and
taysom needs to and maybe you get drew
back
yeah that's you know that's the question
i mean i
i didn't know you had that many ribs
that's that's how i mean my god
you know i and the funny thing was and
you know as a player
players know this i saw his
face and his body language when he got
up
and i know that feeling that feeling is
if you're great you don't know how to
tap out
you can't look to the sideline that's
just not what you do
and that was the realization in his face
and his body language that i'm really
really
really really hurt i mean and how hurt
he was we didn't know how tough is drew
brees
no doubt oh my gosh
you know that's not you don't
necessarily drew brees tough
you know that's you know we we kind of
give that
that title to other quarterbacks but i
gotta tell you
he moved way up on the list he made a
quantum leap
up my list howie long here on the rich
eisen show fox nfl sunday analyst pro
football hall of famer
all right who are the raiders then too i
mean i
i think they're a playoff team i think
they've got thumpers all over the place
uh from the back end of the defense up
front max crosby's a real deal guy i
think we all
know um josh jacobs is is top-notch if
he can stay healthy
derek has been he's been remarkable this
year and then this last week was
i i i is that you you throw it out just
say that's an outlier or what
do you think about the raiders they have
to and
and i think that's important that they
do uh
their fullbacks been banged up i mean
josh jacobs
is uh you know if you don't like josh
jacobs you don't like
you know football right he's he's just a
guy that
you know runs like his hair is on fire
and you know he's just
he does not run away from contact and
you know he's not
a hundred percent and you know they've
we could go to the offensive line kind
of
it's been you know baskins and robin's
now serving
42 you know and it's who's it right
tackle who's a left guard who's a left
tackle
you know the constant you know constants
have been for the most part
center in the right guard but beyond
that that's been about
it you know i
[Music]
our boy mike you know that picture the
president when he goes in office
and then four to eight years later the
picture of him when he goes
i'm telling you mike could look like rip
van winkle
you know in a year or two here
tough it's tough and and you know you
add to it
and we all kind of take it for granted
what the teams are going through
with covet and restrictions and practice
and
you know the one week where the entire
offensive line was quarantined till
saturday you don't know if you're going
to play
you don't know if the game's going to be
rescheduled um
and it wasn't it not only wasn't
rescheduled to move back it was moved up
which that one's a hard one for me to
explain
so i think they have to throw this one
out um
i think they have to be more disciplined
on the back end you know as you
mentioned they have some thumpers back
there that like to hit people
and you know sometimes getting people on
the ground or being in the right spot is
is as important as you know the kind of
wanting to
to hit someone and they they they're
getting healthy
healthier and the defensive front and
they've got to play better on defense
and that's that's that's been the story
all season long
offensively i don't know what the deal
was they
looked horrible last week and we've all
had games like that as a team where
you just kind of you know you look at
the film and you you move on
and that's the best thing you can do
what
this week tells me
you know i i want to see what what how
they respond this week and that will
tell me a lot
about the raiders well they also have a
nice get right opponent in in the jets i
got howie long here on the rich eisen
show
uh talking about uh the raiders just uh
right there and the raiders
without a doubt played the chiefs better
than anybody else has been playing the
chiefs all year long they got one on
them
i know but the wins rich i know they've
got they've got some quality wins
there's no doubt about it and the chiefs
you know uh lost one and uh it could
have the raiders could have easily swept
them but
the chiefs are who they are and rich
anyone who thought it was a fluke up
there in kansas city
they walked out of that stadium thinking
we were lucky to get out of here
oh there's no there's no there's no
doubt about it you know and and
and like i said i i like the raiders
that i'm just
i will just throw that last week out and
see how they can do you know as for the
chiefs they are they are
um even with a team above them in the
standings
because the steelers are undefeated i
think the best team in the time travel
rich
what do you mean by that well we got in
one of those things i don't know what it
is where you shut the door and
suddenly you're in 2040. the delorean
that's what this offense is they are
frightening i mean and here's the thing
that makes them all the more scary
you go back to the first raider game and
andy you know who who loves to throw the
ball and you know that's ironic because
andy's an old offensive lineman
he loves to throw the ball and he said
after that game that
he didn't put his players in position to
be
successful to give them the opportunity
to be successful
and what he meant by that was the run
pass ratio was so out of whack
and you know we've become so one one
dimensional i think the raiders played
coverage and
you know kept everything in front of
them and as we found out last week
you know particularly with tampa bay the
one thing that you can't do
versus kansas city or can't allow are
those explosive plays
and you know who made the decision to
single that guy is
you know i i don't know it's crazy but
you know i i i look at the next week
when they came back
after the raider game and they ran the
ball over 40 times for over 200 yards
and you say to yourself oh my gosh
if they ever you know and and to their
in in andy's defense
he closed out the super bowl that way
you know running the football
but if if they have that kind of balance
what do you do i don't know because
you're talking about that game against
buffalo where they just came in and then
and then
kind of ran three or four different of
the three three or four of the same
plays
right at them and jammed the ball down
their throat and speaking of getting in
the delorean and going into the future
vic fangio went a little bit on the way
back machine today the head coach of the
broncos that's uh
who the chiefs are playing on sunday
night football howie
uh vic fangio said that elway was kind
of the
mahomes of the 80s and 90s i agree
you'd agree with that chris and i talked
about it
you know it's like people don't
understand
john was the hardest guy to pass rush
against
because the tackle can overset you
if you're outside um and if you go
wide on the guard if you're inside if
there's
any kind of a gap he's taking it
particularly down
down you know in the red zone but on
third down you know like let's say a
third down and two chris was looking at
play where was third and two and
you know mahomes drifted to like
you know it's usually a three five step
drop and it's five yards and you know
whatever the number is
he drifts to 16 and
and and drifts to his right or to his
left
and makes a 25-yard throw for a first
down
with a flick of the risk you can't
the ability to what he forces you to do
defensively
is be so stagnant it's like
we have to press the pocket we can't
rush the quarterback
you have to be able to get there with
four and and that's the key because you
have to play coverage versus this team
and you have to do it's really smart uh
that's the key but john was just like
that if you
that tackle would invite you inside if
you took an up and under
john would burst out to his right throw
the ball across the field 70 yards
now put it all together though i'm going
to ask you the ultimate question here
howie
uh because i i mentioned this on nfl
game day morning last week
um on sunday that uh before mahomes was
taking on brady
that in order to match brady in terms of
success and longevity
he needs to win um he needs to go
to eight more super bowls and win five
of them
in the next 18 years to win as many
super bowls
and also play as long as brady and brady
would be
if he does that brady will be 61 years
of age on that day
so my question for you is is mahomes set
up to be the greatest of all time or is
that really
ludicrous to even suggest despite how
great he has looked
so far well i you know i i think he's a
guy that
you know some guys it's you say some
quarterbacks who
you know move around and what kind of
hits are you taking
it's like russell doesn't give you a
clean hit right for the most part the
kid in arizona doesn't
give you a clean hit uh cam
and and the problem with cam was and and
still is
he ever walked up on camis he's all of
six six six
five and for him to get from vertical to
horizontal quickly
is a challenge that's number one he has
to
limit the number of hits and be smart
and and not allow that to happen number
two
is they they have a tremendous
supporting cast around him at wide
receiver running back
and tight end you know kelsey's a hall
of fame
level tight end uh if they
can continue to i think the maybe the
most impressive thing about new england
and what they did and what brady did was
you looked at them on paper and you know
on film and you go
it's okay but they're so they were so
well coached so
disciplined and tom was
such an extension of the head coach
and and the kind of style that they
wanted and you think about all the super
bowls they want
what's the average winning
total of each super bowl well that's
like three
three points they win they won
close super bowls it's not like they
were blowing people out
the more that kansas city over the years
surrounds him with talent
and can show that they can listen they
came from behind
in every playoff game last year 10 or
more points down
maybe the last time we see that though
howie you know i think to your point
here because andy reads
and he's not going anywhere either he's
he's in his early 60s you know
so yeah they have a shot here like i
think legitimately he has we're already
treating him in
in the media uh like michael jordan or
or somebody of that ilk in the way that
why would we give him mvp when you know
he's already been there and done that
let's let's kind of spread it around to
people
i don't know mvp's uh that's a
complicated conversation and it's
well well beyond my pay grade right but
he has a chance i think when it's all
said and done to
to match tom it's entirely because he he
certainly is the guy
that that you look at but what it re
he said he's at base camp too
okay so look
it's one thing a lot of people have
fallen short just before the summit
yes on one year
think about what tom did and think about
what new england did
we will never i i don't think i don't
think we're ever going to see it again
i i don't uh it's too hard
it's just too and you know it's not a
game like basketball or baseball where
you know you got a little hamstring
tweak or something
in football we see it every week rich
people go down every week
and it changes the dynamic on a football
team and
uh maybe the dynamic or the trajectory
of their
season so uh last one for you how i know
we've been on a while but uh just a
couple minutes left here if you can
um i mean because uh if you can because
it is a very
thorny subject do you think tom brady
and aryans and
this offense can pull it together in a
more consistent manner and you mentioned
defensively
uh you know going sing along tyreek hill
only gave up 200 yards
to one player in just one quarter do you
think tampa can pull it together and
and become super bowl uh candidates
when it is like i like their defense a
lot i like todd bowles a lot
um i think they they made a mistake in
the first quarter
and obviously that's hey you know duh
he had over 200 yards in the first
quarter
think about that he had over 200 yards
in the first quarter yes
that's that's it that's my that's
illegal they should have arrested him
right there on the field
i mean that you shouldn't be able to do
that
so you know i i think moving forward you
know they end up losing 20
with 27 24 yes and and kansas city gets
the first down
and and runs out the clock um
i like their defense uh offensively
is is really where the rubik's cube is
um for them they they have all the
pieces
they really do they have some injuries
in the offensive line which are
concerning
i i i wish they ran more play action
i wish they had someone who's more like
maybe white
in new england or you know he's had like
you know through we talked about tom's
kind of run
in new england how many running backs
that tom have in new england but
running backs it now could run but were
great out of the backfield in the screen
game
and play action pass and all those
things that they don't
do and and the other part in new england
that was
reassuring for tom was tom wants to know
where you're going to be on every throw
exactly where you're going to be not two
yards this way or
maybe he thinks you're going right
you're going left
i believe they have options in their
routes
for the receivers i i'm not
you know specifically sure about that
but that's what i've heard
that's not what tom wants
tom wants now at some point i think
you know everyone needs to get in a room
and say what do we need to do to get
this thing right and
this is a team that can win the whole
thing it really is and people say well
you know week to week it's fodder on tv
that has tom falling off a cliff
it's you know it and it's minute by
minute almost
it's it's a joke and and you know he'll
look
tom looks good to me tom looks fine to
me
it's they need to be in sync and that
was always the question down there
we knew what bruce's offense looked like
bruce's offenses
throw the ball down the field you're
gonna throw some interceptions
you're gonna take a lot of hits that
doesn't work for this quarterback if you
brought this quarterback in
you have to adapt to him and
you have to adapt the passing game to
him
and it would certainly help your
offensive line out to run the football
run play action pass
how are you the man thanks for the call
great shout out always love when no we
get together best to your awesome family
uh happy holidays in advance and maybe
uh in the playoffs we'll get you on the
line
yeah likewise rich talking with you stay
well you too that's howie long
the best i love that guy man
football royalty the whole family
fantastic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here